as Maria said for ilion's are facing
fuel shortages already a number of gas
stations up and down Florida's east
coast from Jacksonville to Miami have
all running already run out and in an
effort to restock supplies Governor Ron
de Santos ordered highway patrol cars to
escort tanker trucks to their
destinations as Dorian approaches
anxiety is getting higher on the roads
and in Florida's busiest travel hubs
this holiday weekend
mark Strassmann is in st. Augustine with
that part of the story mark good morning
good morning it's Labor Day weekend and
yet deserted streets like this one are
about to become routine in tourist
destinations like st. Augustine
America's oldest city tourists and
residents alike
everyone's tracking the storm in their
own way hurricane anxiety grips coastal
Florida as Dorian makes its slow
approach there are long lines for gas
and in some places plastic bags covering
the pumps a sold-out sign to drivers in
need of fuel to look elsewhere I do
understand that there is a drain on the
entire East Coast of Florida however no
one saw this coming the pain may be just
beginning for air travelers airlines are
already sending out alerts to passengers
traveling through the state home to four
of the nation's biggest airports on
Friday eight carriers started offering
waivers allowing passengers to change
their flights throughout the state
without paying a fee Miami's a hub for
American Airlines which is offering
waivers to 13 of the 16 airports they
servers throughout the state but with
dorians still a few days away some
fliers are making their getaway now I
was really really worried about having
to change my flights and and all my
hotels being canceled and stuff like
that
I'm gonna be leaving earlier than the
hurricane gets their venture does they
release doing it was a nightmare to get
the flight to come back sooner
day by day here travel options will keep
dropping by 2:00 a.m. Monday morning
airports in both Orlando and Daytona
Beach will close Dana
mark Strassmann thank you Mark